well at least 920 people have been
killed and hundreds more injured in an
earthquake in afghanistan the 6.1
magnitude quake happened in the south
east of the country it's believed to
have struck about 27 miles from the city
of coast and it's now understood that
more than 600 people have been hurt
footage that emerged from paktika
province showed rescuers arriving by air
and you can see people being carried
away by helicopter and
the damage that has been caused to a lot
of these structures uh let's bring in
skies injurement recede who is in lahore
in pakistan for us uh inzi what can you
tell us about the situation this this is
quite a remote area isn't it
yeah a very remote area and i think
that's what has made it extremely
difficult for aid agencies to get into
the region it is very early days but
this was a huge earthquake a very
powerful
earthquake that struck the mountainous
region
of uh paktika in afghanistan um the
latest numbers that we understand now
are around 950 people have died from
this quake and around 600 people are
injured but the afghani authorities
the interior minister saludin ayubi has
said that the death toll is likely to
rise as some of the villages are in
remote areas in the mountains and it
will take some time to collect details
now what is quite striking is that ever
since the taliban took over afghanistan
it's been
incredibly difficult for authorities to
work
on the ground it means that rescue
efforts are likely to be complicated
over the next
hours and days since a lot of the main
aid agencies the international aid
agencies left afghanistan since the
taliban took over the country last year
and that will be a cause a huge knock-on
effect to that rescue mission and no
doubt will increase that death toll as a
result but as we understand it on the
ground and we can see from some of the
pictures
that people locals are trying to
rescue people from the rubble we've seen
some other images on social media as
well which shows that houses completely
crushed we've seen cars
and villages as well in these remote
areas completely destroyed as a result
and that death toll will no doubt rise
currently around
950 people at least have died from this
earthquake in the paktika area of
afghanistan around 600
have been injured and the officials in
afghanistan saying that that death toll
will no doubt rise pakistan here they've
said that they will be on standby to
send any aid that is required of course
a neighboring country with borders to
and from into afghanistan the former
prime minister imran khan has said that
the area in pakistan which neighbours
that area afghanistan which has been
affected they are prepared to assist
with
medical assistance and any financial
assistance
they require but clearly
an issue in terms of the aid agencies
now in afghanistan who will not be able
to try and help and react to this
incident as many of them were pulled out
when the taliban took over last year and
that has been a huge issue and will be a
huge issue as this rescue mission
continues with over 950 people now dead
okay indie thanks very much for that
indie bear with the latest for us from
pakistan